[Musik]
Königin Elisabeth II hat ihr ganzes
Leben in den Dienst der Krone und denen
ihres Landes gestellt in guten wie in
schlechten Zeiten sie bestiegt den Thron
des Vereinigten Königreichs viel früher
als erwartet als Prinzessin reiste sie
ab als Königin hätte sie wieder in ein
Land im Schockzustand
eine außergewöhnliche Frau die drei
Viertel ihres Lebens auf dem Thron
verbracht hat mit der Krönung von
Königin Elisabeth begann eine neue Ära
sie hat das Vereinigte Königreich in
sozialen wie politischen Krisen
zusammengehalten und war eine Konstante
in Jahren der Unruhe und des Wandels
Land große Krisen durchgemacht hat war
die Queen da und hat das Land geeint
als britische Königin und als Oberhaupt
des Commonwealth war sie über 70 Jahre
lang eine der bekanntesten
Persönlichkeiten ihrer Zeit und hat auch
das Fernsehzeitalter geprägt die Queen
war das perfekte Vorbild für uns
Pflichterfüllung war ihre Berufung
die oberbefehlshaberin der britischen
Streitkräfte war 14 Jahre alt als sie
das erste Mal über Funk zu ihren
Landsleuten sprach
und tat dies bis ins hohe Alter
[Musik]
Elisabeth II ist eine der großen
Persönlichkeiten des 20 und 21
jahrhunderts eine Königin mit der die
britische Monarchie den Sprung in die
Moderne geschafft hat
[Musik]
kein britischer Monarch regierte Länge
als Königin Elisabeth II als sie 1952
den Thron des Vereinigten Königreichs
bestieg herrschte Stalin noch in der
Sowjetunion und Truman war Präsident der
USA sie erlebte mehr Premierminister
ihres Landes und traf mehr
Staatsoberhäupter als jeder andere
britische Monarch in der Geschichte
[Musik]
die ständig im Wandel ist in der sich
nicht nur die Menschen verändern sondern
auch die Umstände in denen sie leben und
arbeiten in einer Welt in der sie
umziehen und alles mögliche ausprobieren
war sie die große beruhigende konstante
die über 70 Jahre an der Spitze der
Nation statt das ist eine bemerkenswert
lange Zeit
sie war immer da in guten wie in
schlechten Zeiten Jahrzehnte lang sie
einte unser Land sie war der rote Faden
der alles und alle zusammen gehalten hat
[Musik]
als Elizabeth Alexandra Mary Winzer am
21 April 1926 das Licht der Welt
erblickt ist es ihr keineswegs bestimmt
Königin zu werden
ihre Kindheit verbringt sie mit der
Familie die ihr Vater liebevoll als wir
vier bezeichnet ihr Kosename zu Hause
ist Lilly Bett
Elizabeth hat eine herzliche Beziehung
zu beiden Elternteilen aber die enge
Bindung zu ihrem Vater kommt ihr
besonders zu guter als sie älter wird
denn das Leben der Familie ändert sich
radikal als ihr Onkel King Edward der
achte 1936 die geschiedene Amerikanerin
Wallace Simpson heiratet ein Skandal der
ihn zur Abdankung zwingt
das Jahr 1936 war traumatisch für
Prinzessin Elizabeth denn ihr geliebter
Onkel David also Edward der achte dem
sie immer vertraut hatte verriet sein
heiliges versprechen es war ein
schrecklicher Moment der Schande für die
ganze Familie
Abdankung ist für Sie daher während all
der Jahre auf dem Thron nie in Frage
gekommen
Elisabeths Vater tritt an die Stelle des
älteren Bruders und wird im Mai 1937 als
King George der sechste gekrönt
[Musik]
1936 gezwungenermaßen und ohne hier
darauf vorbereitet worden zu sein er
hatte große Angst kann guter König zu
sein zum Glück hat er eine starke Frau
und seiner Seite sie unterstützt ihn in
jeder Hinsicht dabei einen guter König
zu werden
[Musik]
schüchterner stotternder Vater hatte nie
damit gerechnet sein Land anzuführen und
das auch noch in Zeiten eines bald
einsetzenden Krieges in diesem schweren
Jahren versammeln er und Premierminister
Winston Churchill die Briten hinter sich
um gegen die Deutschen und ihre
Verbündeten zu kämpfen
der König bereitet seine junge Tochter
auf den Titel vor den sie einmal tragen
wird Ihre Majestät Königin Elisabeth II
the queenland hat die Lehrjahre der
Queen waren auch Krisenjahre sie fallen
in die Zeit nach der Abdankung als die
Gefahr bestand dass die Monarchie
untergehen könnte
doch Elizabeth damals noch Prinzessin
nahm sich ihren Vater als Vorbild sie
hatte sein Pflichtbewusstsein geerbt und
wurde seine Schülerin
[Musik]
1940 folgt die damals 14-Jährige dem
Beispiel ihres Vaters sie wendet sich
über das Radio an die Kinder des Landes
die wegen der Deutschen bombatements aus
den Städten evakuiert werden mussten
meistens
[Musik]
to be away from there is we love me to
go
Meister ist bei my side and we are Burst
going to say good night to you kann man
Margit good night good night and good
luck to you
die Kriegsjahre verbringen die
Prinzessinnen Elisabeth und Margaret
überwiegend auf Schloss Windsor
wie viele andere Kinder in
Großbritannien sind auch sie häufig von
ihrer Familie getrennt
denn die Eltern der Queen bleiben im
Buckingham Palace trotz der vielen
Bombenangriffe der deutschen auf die
Londoner Innenstadt
die Tatsache dass der König und die
Königin während des Krieges in London
blieben und ihr Leben riskierten zeigte
der Prinzessin ein weiteres Mal wie
wichtig Pflichterfüllung war
überhaupt wurde für sie das Wort Pflicht
für seine Art Motto für den Rest ihres
Lebens
1947 unternimmt Elizabeth ihre erste
Auslandsreise sie begleitet ihre Eltern
in südliche Afrika es heißt dies sei für
sie die glücklichste Zeit mit ihrer
Familie gewesen die Prinzessin hält von
unterwegs anlässlich ihres 21
geburtstags eine Radioansprache an das
British Commonwealth
it my her live
[Musik]
Imperial family all the long
die Worte der Prinzessin klingen
authentisch und überzeugend nach ihrer
Rückkehr heiratet sie noch im selben
Jahr Prinz Philip von Griechenland und
Dänemark
vom Balkon des Palasts winken Elisabeth
und ihr Mann der jubelnden Menge zu
die Öffentlichkeit war begeistert von
dem verliebten Paar und der Tatsache
dass ihre geliebte Prinzessin so
glücklich war nach dem Krieg sehnten
sich die Menschen nach guten Nachrichten
1952 verschlechtert sich der
Gesundheitszustand des Königs und das
junge Paar übernimmt einige seiner
Verpflichtungen
[Musik]
doch schon bald wird es offensichtlich
dass mit dem König etwas nicht stimmt
niemand wusste dass der König krank war
nicht mal ihm selbst sagte man dass er
Lungenkrebs hatte er war an seinen
Fünfzigern alle hofften er würde noch
mindestens 20 Jahre regieren
[Musik]
am 31 januar 1952 verabschiedet der
Vater die Tochter auf eine königliche
Reise nach Kenia
an diesem Tag sieht Elizabeth ihn zum
letzten Mal
nur eine Woche später stirbt King George
der sechste im Schlaf mit nur 56 Jahren
ich war sechs Jahre alt mein Vater war
damals noch Soldat wir wohnten in London
in padney und ich erinnere mich dass
mein Vater viel früher als sonst nach
Hause kam denn eigentlich war der
tagsüber ja bei der Arbeit
ich höre und sehe ihn noch ganz genau
wie er da stand und sagte meine liebe
Familie der König ist tot
über Nacht ändert sich das Leben der
Prinzessin die nun die Rückreise
antreten muss und als Königin Elisabeth
II nach Großbritannien zurückkehrt
die Regierung ist versammelt um die neue
Königin zu begrüßen
am 2 juni 1953 findet die
Krönungszeremonie in der Westminster
Abbey statt
nach den kargen und düsteren
Nachkriegsjahren ist es ein Augenblick
voller Stolz und Optimismus
[Applaus]
weltweit verfolgen Millionen von
Menschen die erste TV-Übertragung dieser
Art
der Verkauf von Fernsehgeräten in
Großbritannien schnell in die Höhe alle
wollen sehen wie die neue Königin ihren
krönungsalt ablegt
ich fand die Krönung unglaublich toll
ich ging damals noch zur Schule
ich erinnere mich dass ich den
Diamantring meiner Mutter nahm und das
Datum der Krönung in die Fensterscheibe
ritzte es war ein fantastisches Erlebnis
für alle ein Riesenspektakel man könnte
sagen dass sie damals auch einen Bund
mit der Nation geschlossen hat und dass
sie sozusagen von Gott zur Königin
gesalbt wurde denn darum geht es ja bei
dieser Zeremonie die Queen ist gläubig
ich denke das war ein wichtiger Aspekt
für Sie
Großbritannien hat zwar den Krieg
gewonnen doch der Preis dafür war hoch
der Wiederaufbau und die Wirtschaft
laufen schleppend viele erhoffen sich
von der neuen Königin Inspiration und
Ermutigung eine Hoffnung die sie nicht
enttäuschen wird
der Krönung von Königin Elisabeth begann
eine neue Ära ein Gefühl von Aufbruch
nach all den dunklen Kriegsjahren der
schweren Nachkriegszeit mit den
Rationierungen der Lebensmittelknappheit
und den von Bomben zerstörten Städten
endlich schien es wieder bergauf zu
gehen
[Musik]
Großbritannien sucht aber auch seinen
Platz in der neuen Zeit und durchlebt
eine Identitätskrise denn die
ruhmreichen Tage des weltumspannenden
British Empire neigen sich dem Ende zu
viele Kolonien fordern ihre
Unabhängigkeit aus diesen Ländern
entsteht ein Verbund aus 54 souveränen
Mitgliedstaaten das Commonwealth of
Nations mit der Queen als Oberhaupt
am 24 november 1953 beginnt Elizabeth
ihre Weltreise durch die britischen
Kolonien und das Commonwealth es ist
eine der wichtigsten Royal Tours aller
Zeiten die Queen legt über 64.000 km
zurück bereits 13 Länder und mehrere
Kontinente per Flugzeug Schiff und Zug
von der kleinen südpazifikinsel Fidschi
bis in die Hauptstadt Ugandas ihre
Mission ist von großer Bedeutung
ihre größte royal-tour unternahm die
Queen 1953 und 54 nach ihrer Krönung sie
verfolgte damit zwei Ziele es war
einerseits ihre antrittsreise als neue
Königin und zugleich die erste Chance
Großbritanniens sich beim Empire und
beim Commonwealth für die Unterstützung
im Zweiten Weltkrieg zu bedanken
verglichen mit jeder anderen Figur des
öffentlichen Lebens ist die Queen ein
politisch neutrales Staatsoberhaupt dass
die Commonwealth-Staaten um sich herum
vereinen kann und gerade weil sie ihre
eigene Meinung in der Öffentlichkeit nie
äußert kann sie eine wichtige Rolle
dabei spielen die Interessen der
ehemaligen Kolonien zu fördern
sie war wie eine Art Katalysator
beispielsweise wenn sie an den Gipfel
Treffen der Commonwealth Staatschefs
teilnahmen gerne zwei Jahren einem der
Mitgliedsländer stattfanden wenn es dort
zu Meinungsverschiedenheiten zwischen
zwei Ländern kam sprach sie mit den
jeweiligen Staatschefs und war wie eine
Botschafterin zwischen den beiden Seiten
wenn die Betroffenen Staatschefs dann am
Ende eines solchen Treffens wieder
miteinander redeten hatte sie ihre
Mission erfüllt und den Dialog
wiederhergestellt
mit dem Ende der 1950er Jahre muss
Elisabeth II die Monarchie wieder einmal
neu ausrichten denn auf die patriotische
Stimmung der Nachkriegszeit folgt die
rebellische Gegenkultur der 1960er Jahre
großbritannien hatte sich im Laufe der
50er Jahre sehr verändert zu Beginn
dominierte die Nachkriegszeit alles war
knapp manche Kinder hatten noch nie eine
Banane gesehen Ende der 50er gab es
wieder Geld und Glamour das Land stand
an der Schwelle zu den 60er Jahren mit
Minirock corned Street und den Beatles
die Katerstimmung nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg wird abgelöst von einer
lebendigen Kulturrevolution
Großbritannien wird berühmt für Popmusik
und Mode
die Monarchin kann auch damit auf ihre
Art Schritt halten zur schmalen Taille
und den weiten Rücken der 1950er Jahre
kommen die kurzen Jäckchen und schicken
Hüte der Sixties
Königin Stilikone und Mutter
1964 ist Queen Elizabeth Mutter von vier
Kindern dem Thronfolger Prinz Charles
der Princess Royal Princess Anne Prinz
Andrew des Duke of York und Prinz Edward
OHL of Wessex
die Familie lebt überwiegend im Backen
im Palace in London verbringt die Ferien
jedoch oft auf dem schottischen Land
sitzt bermoil oder Sandringham in North
die Königin kommt ihren Pflichten als
Ehefrau und Mutter ebenso nach wie denen
als Staatsoberhaupt
[Musik]
es war von Anfang an akzeptiert dass
Prinz Philip die Rolle des
Familienoberhaupts übernimmt sie trug
die Krone er hatte die Hosen an
Entscheidungen über die Gestaltung der
Wohnräume Haushalts- oder
Erziehungsfragen auch wo die Kinder zur
Schule gehen sollten alle dafür
relevanten Entscheidungen traf er
in einer Zeit die seien wir ehrlich von
Chauvinismus geprägt war als Frauen noch
nicht Karriere machten als Frauen noch
keine Führungspositionen in Unternehmen
inne hatten und auch keine wichtigen
Posten bekleideten da stand nun diese
junge Frau mit ihren 25 Jahren an der
Spitze unserer Regierung und unserer
konstitutionellen Monarchie
[Musik]
die 1970er Jahre bringen erneut große
Herausforderungen für die Monarchie und
das Vereinigte Königreich die Queen ist
jetzt Mitte 40 und die Probleme zu Hause
und auch in der Welt spitzen sich zu
Nordirland rechts unter brutalen
konfessionellen Konflikten in England
kommt es zu Stromausfällen zu Streiks
und zum sogenannten Winter der
Unzufriedenheit dazu erreicht die Zahl
der Arbeitslosen zum ersten Mal seit den
1930er Jahren die Marke von einer
Million
die 70er Jahre waren eine schwierige
Phase viele Streiks die drei Tage Woche
steigenden flaktionen und immer mehr
Arbeitslose
die Königin weiß um die schlechte
Stimmung im Lande sie entscheidet sich
für einen nahbareren Ansatz
1977 begann die Queen mit ihren
sogenannten Walkabouts die Medien
reagierten darauf sofort sehr positiv
wow schaut euch das an die Königin macht
einen Spaziergang
auf die sogenannten Walkabouts the Queen
folgt bald die Party des Jahrzehnts der
1977 feiert Elisabeth II ihr silbernes
tonjubiläum
und eine Million Menschen säumen die
Straßen Londons in der Hoffnung ihre
Königin für einen kurzen Moment zu
erblicken
weitere 500 Millionen im Commonwealth
verfolgen die Ereignisse live im
Fernsehen
die Straßen sind rot weiß und blau
geschmückt
das Vereinigte Königreich feiert seine
Königin und ihre ersten 25 Jahre auf dem
Thron
[Applaus]
die Queen und ihre Familie stehen seit
Beginn ihrer Herrschaft im Mittelpunkt
des öffentlichen Interesses und das ganz
besonders am 29 juli 1981 als ihr
ältester Sohn Charles Dianas Benzer
heiratet
an diesem Tag verfolgen 750 Millionen
Menschen die Feierlichkeiten die einer
Märchenhochzeit sehr nahekommen
ein Jahr nach der royalen Hochzeit wird
Prinz William geboren Charles und Dianas
erster Sohn sein jüngerer Bruder Prinz
Harry erblickt zwei Jahre später das
Licht der Welt doch da machen die
Eheprobleme der Eltern bereits
Schlagzeilen
den Ehekrieg von Charles und Diana im
Fernsehen zu verfolgen passt die
Zuschauer natürlich brennend
interessierte muss schwer erträglich
gewesen sein für die Queen für eine Frau
ihrer Generation die niemals öffentlich
schmutzige Wäsche gewaschen hätte war es
sicherlich sehr bitter den eigenen Sohn
und ihre Schwiegertochter vor laufenden
TV-Kameras streiten zu sehen
Ende der 1980er Jahre ist es
unübersehbar dass die Beziehung zwischen
Charles und Diana nicht mehr zu kitten
ist
die Tür der Queen stand auch in den
schwersten Zeiten immer offen für ihren
Sohn den Prince of Wales sowie für Diana
die Princess of Wales aber irgendwann
war man sich am Ende einig das
letztendlich eine Scheidung das Beste
sei sowohl für die beiden Eheleute als
auch für die Monarchie
die Queen tut weiterhin das was sie seit
über 30 Jahren zu tun pflegt sie erfüllt
ihre Pflichten und bietet ein offenes
Ohr und Rad an wenn es angemessen ist
doch nichts kann die Obsession der
Medien mit Diana und dem Beziehungsdrama
mit Charles dämpfen
[Musik]
1992 erweist sich als eines der
schwersten Jahre für die Queen drei
ihrer Kinder Prinz Charles Prinz Andrew
und Princess an geben ihre Trennung oder
Scheidung bekannt
[Musik]
neben gescheiterten Ehen in der Familie
muss die Queen weitere Krisen bewältigen
[Musik]
am Abend ihres 45 Hochzeitstages bricht
ein Feuer in Schloss windsar aus und
zerstört kostbare Bilder und Erbstücke
auch mehrere Räume in den königlichen
Wohnungen werden verwüstet Bilder werden
in aller Eile von den Wänden genommen
Rembrandts Games Bros eine riesige
Sammlung unersetzlicher Kunst
[Musik]
die Königin hält eine bemerkenswerte
Rede sie spricht von einem anosuribiles
ihrem Schreckensjahr
[Musik]
die 1990er sind bewegte Jahre für die
Königin
zu den düstersten Momenten ihrer
Regentschaft zählt der Tod von Lady
Diana Princess of Wales
[Musik]
am 31 August 1997 Rast das Auto in dem
die Prinzessin sitzt mit hoher
Geschwindigkeit in einem Tunnel in Paris
gegen einen Pfeiler
Diana stirbt kurz darauf im Krankenhaus
ihre Söhne Prinz William und Prinz Harry
verbringen gerade den Sommer mit der
Queen in barmoral als sie die Nachricht
vom tödlichen Unfall ihrer Mutter
erreicht Queen ganz Großmutter entschied
sich die beiden Jungen bei sich zu
behalten die Fernsehgeräte auszuschalten
und ihre Enkel in belmael zu schützen
sie sorgte sich sehr um William und
Harry in den folgenden Stunden und Tagen
trauert die Öffentlichkeit mit einem
Schmerz um Diana wie man es im
Vereinigten Königreich so noch nicht
erlebt hat
[Musik]
die Königin folgte normalerweise dem
Grundsatz dass das Leben weitergeht und
man weitermacht wie gehabt egal was
geschehen ist mit dieser Methode hatte
sie bereits zahlreiche zum Teil schwere
Krisen während ihre Herrschaft
gemeistert doch dieses mal funktionierte
das überhaupt nicht denn die Menschen
wollten nicht dass die Queen einfach
stoisch weitermacht sondern dass sie
Emotionen und Gefühle zulässt und Ihnen
diese auch zeigt und übermittelt
[Musik]
am 5 September einen Tag vor der jenes
Beerdigung kehrt die Queen nach London
zurück und hält eine bewegende Rede vom
Balkon des Buckingham Palace ihre Worte
werden live übertragen
[Musik]
mother I say from my heart
first I want pay tribute
sprach zu uns als Königin und als
Großmutter mit einer Vertrautheit die
sie so noch nie in einer öffentlichen
Rede gezeigt hatte die Leute
realisierten dass sie nicht nur unser
Staatsoberhaupt sondern auch eine
liebende fürsorgende Frau ist
Elizabeth korrigierte das Bild dass die
Menschen von ihr in dieser schweren Zeit
bekommen hatten
mit dem neuen Jahrtausend beginnt eine
neue Ära für das Königshaus und für die
Königin Mutter stehen große
Feierlichkeiten an
[Musik]
im Jahr 2000 feiert die Queen Mum ihren
100 Geburtstag seit sie 1923 den
späteren King George den sechsten
geheiratet hat steht sie im Licht der
Öffentlichkeit viele Briten verehrten
die Queen Mother wegen ihrer Verbindung
zum König und wegen ihrer wichtigen
Rolle im Krieg als Übermutter der
britischen Bevölkerung
wir sind mit dir aufgewachsen es gab
keine andere
[Musik]
lieblingsomi
die Materialien der Monarchie ist bis
dahin das einzige Mitglied der
königlichen Familie das ein ganzes
Jahrhundert erlebt hat
2002 schließt sie für immer die Augen
innerhalb weniger Wochen muss Queen
Elizabeth sowohl ihre Schwester Margaret
als auch ihre Mutter zu Grabe tragen
[Musik]
ich fand immer faszinierend wie die
Queen mit tragischen Ereignissen fertig
wird
i thank you for the support
[Applaus]
[Musik]
seit dem Tod ihres Vaters ist ein halbes
Jahrhundert vergangen und damit 50 Jahre
seit ihrer Thronbesteigung trotz der
Trauer um ihre Mutter und Schwester
begeht die Queen 2002 ihr goldenes
tonjubiläum und dankt auf diese Weise
auch der Nation für ihre Treue
die Menschen feierten das Jubiläum als
Fest für das lange leben der Königin für
sie selbst war es die Gelegenheit den
Schwur mit dem sie sich ihrem Land und
ihrem Volk verpflichtet hatte noch
einmal zu bekräftigen
im April 2002 erneuert die Queen vor dem
Parlament ihren krönungseid und erklärt
ihre Absicht ihrem Land auch weiterhin
als konstitutionelle Monarchen zu dienen
[Musik]
Wars the best of myability
through the changing times ahead
drei Jahre später im Jahr 2005 geben
Prinz Charles und Camilla Parker bowls
bekannt dass sie heiraten wollen nach
einer Liebesbeziehung die über 30 Jahre
bestanden hatte
das hat den Prince of Wales sehr
glücklich gemacht er erfüllte seine
Pflichten jetzt mit wesentlich größerer
Zufriedenheit er war ausgeglichener und
entspannter ich glaube dass ich darüber
auch die Queen sehr gefreut hat
Königin Elisabeth verkündet das Camilla
Parker bowls künftig als ihre königliche
Hoheit die Herzogin von Cornwall
anzusprechen sei
2011 ist die Queen mit 85 Jahren
Ehrengast bei der Hochzeit auf die alle
gewartet haben am 29 April schließt ihr
Enkel Prinz William die Ehe mit seiner
Liebe aus Studentenzeiten Kate Middleton
im Vereinigten Königreich ist es das
Ereignis des Jahrzehnts
die Zeremonie findet in der Westminster
Abbey statt weltweit schauen dabei über
eine Milliarde Menschen zu es ist eines
der größten TV-Events aller Zeiten
als Prinz William und Princess Catherine
aus der Westminster Abbey treten jubelt
die Menge
[Musik]
die Queen hielt sich an diesem Tag sehr
im Hintergrund denn sie war nicht die
Hauptperson es gibt solche Tage wenn
andere im Rampenlicht stehen
und das war an diesem Tag
selbstverständlich die Braut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für die königliche Familie ist es ein
Tag der Freude und des Glücks
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber schon im Monat darauf schreibt die
Queen ein weiteres Mal Geschichte
[Musik]
als erste britische Monarchin macht sie
einen Staatsbesuch in der Republik
Irland
es ist eine Geste der Versöhnung für die
sie weltweit gelobt wird
bei ihrer Rede im Dublin Castle spricht
sie auch über das Leid dass die
Konflikte der Vergangenheit über die
Menschen gebracht haben
wieder spielt Königin Elisabeth ihre
einzigartige Rolle auf internationaler
Bühne mit Erfolg aber dabei soll es
nicht bleiben
schon wenige Wochen später begrüßt sie
Barack Obama während seines offiziellen
Staatsbesuchs er ist der zehnte
amtierende US-Präsident den sie empfängt
sein Besuch wird mit 41 Salutschüssen
gewürdigt
ich glaube die amerikanischen
Präsidenten kamen immer voller Ehrfurcht
vor der Königin nach Großbritannien
damals beginnt eine herzliche
Freundschaft zwischen den Royals und den
Obama's witzig oder als der australische
Premierminister Paul Keating seinen Arm
um die Königin legte waren alle empört
man beschimpfte ihn als Lizard of Oz
aber alle waren begeistert von der
Umarmung zwischen der Queen und misses
Obama
auch 2012 dominiert die Königin die
Schlagzeilen denn das Vereinigte
Königreich feiert ihr
diamantenestonjubiläum
nun ist Elizabeth II britische Monarchin
deren Herrschaft sich über 60 Jahre
erstreckt hat
[Musik]
friends celebrating together happy
Atmosphäre i hate memories
für many yes come
[Musik]
mit einem Hoch auf seine Mutter rundet
Prinz Charles die feierliche
Abschlussveranstaltung ab
bis dahin
[Applaus]
drei Jahre später bricht Queen Elizabeth
mit ihrer 63-Jährigen Regentschaft den
Rekord von Königin Victoria
[Musik]
zwei Jahre nach der spektakulären
Hochzeit von William und Kate ist das
Land in baby-taumel
die ganze Welt hatte mit der Queen auf
die Geburt ihres ersten Urenkels
gewartet am 22 juli 2013 war es soweit
mit der Geburt von Prinz George
[Musik]
es war ein ganz besonderer Moment
besonders für die Nationen und gewiss
auch ganz besonders für die Königin
zum ersten Mal seit über 100 Jahren hat
das Land vier königliche Generationen
[Musik]
2016 beginnt die dienstälteste Monarchin
der Briten ihren 90 Geburtstag
zigtausende Landsleute feiern mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
anlässlich des offiziellen
geburtstagsjubiläums wird die Straße vor
dem Buckingham Palace the Marl zum Ort
eines riesigen straßenfests mit Picknick
und Veranstaltungen für 10.000 Gäste und
nicht nur die queen feiert einen runden
Geburtstag ihr Mann Prinz Philip wurde
gerade 95 die beiden sind zu diesem
Zeitpunkt über 70 Jahre verheiratet
[Applaus]
[Musik]
is the one is central in greaden
bei der Krönung der Queen hatte Prinz
Philip geschworen der Lehnsmann von Leib
und Leben ihrer Majestät zu sein an
diesen Schwur hat er sich über sieben
Jahrzehnte gehalten
ihr Mann war die Person im Leben der
Queen der sie bedingungslos vertrauen
konnte sie stritten auch öfters mal aber
man sah sie auch oft herzlich zusammen
lachen sie kamen gut miteinander aus und
waren enger Freunde fürs Leben
2017 zieht sich Prinz Philip von seinen
öffentlichen Ämtern zurück
[Musik]
vor dem Buckingham Palace nimmt der
96-jährige als Captain General der Royal
Marines die Parade ab nach 65
Dienstjahren
2018 heiraten Prinz Harry und Meghan
markle in the strots chapel in Windsor
auch sie feiern eine Märchenhochzeit
eine perfekte Kombination von königlich
britischer Tradition und Hollywood
glamour und anders als alles andere
bisher
this wedding diese Hochzeit fühlte sich
wie etwas Neues an einfach anders modern
tausende kamen um Zeugen dieses
historischen Augenblicks zu werden und
natürlich war auch die Queen zugegen sie
sah fantastisch aus und ich glaube dass
sie überglücklich war dass auch der Duke
of Edinburgh der nur wenige Wochen zuvor
an der Hüfte operiert worden war an
ihrer Seite sein konnte als einer ihrer
Lieblings Enkel heiratete die Freude
darüber war ihr deutlich anzusehen
der Sohn von Harry und Meghan wird ein
Jahr später als Achter Urenkel der Queen
geboren
als seine Eltern heirateten war
Elizabeth schon seit 66 Jahren auf dem
Thron und 92 Jahre alt
ihre Auslandsreisen und ihre königliche
Aufgaben lasst hatte sie zu diesem
Zeitpunkt bereits zurückgeschraubt
2018 hatte sie Prinz Charles zu ihrem
Nachfolger als Oberhaupt des
Commonwealth Berufen eine Position die
als erster ihr Vater King George
eingenommen hatte über 70 Jahre zuvor
wo sind Oberhaupt des Commonwealth of
Nations darauf gibt es kein Erbrecht
alle Mitgliedstaaten des Commonwealth
mussten der Übertragung dieses Amtes an
Prinz Charles zustimmen zwar wusste man
dass die Queen Charles sehr gern als
künftiges Oberhaupt des Commonwealth
sehen würde doch das war kein
Selbstläufer insofern glaube ich dass
sie und ihr Sohn durchaus erleichtert
waren als sich die Mitgliedstaaten des
Commonwealth einstimmig für Prinz
Charles Aussprachen die Übergabe ist
auch ein klares Zeichen dafür dass die
Queen ihre königliche Präsenz reduzieren
und Platz für ihren Sohn machen will
damit hat die Queen in der königlichen
Familie aber auch vor einer breiten
Öffentlichkeit eines klargemacht nämlich
das Charles sich ab jetzt nicht mehr nur
darauf vorbereitet ihre Nachfolge
anzutreten sondern dass er eine
zunehmend wichtige Rolle spielt
2020 geht ein neuer Riss durch die
königliche Familie eine Situation die
der Queen viel abverlangt um weiterhin
ihre stoische Ruhe ausstrahlen zu können
am 8 Januar 2020 schocken der Duke und
die dutches of Sussex den Palast und die
Welt mit der Mitteilung sie würden sich
weitgehend von ihren royalen
Verpflichtungen zurückziehen
die Königin war entsetzt man hatte zwar
darüber gesprochen ja aber das Thema war
für sie längst noch nicht so
ausdiskutiert als dass man damit an die
Öffentlichkeit hätte gehen können eine
derartige Brüskierung vor aller Augen
muss für sie unglaublich enttäuschend
gewesen sein und auf einem ganz
persönlichen Level auch schmerzhaft
etwas später erklärt der Palast des
Harry und Meghan ihre königlichen Titel
ablegen werden und nicht länger als
offizielle Vertreter der Monarchen
auftreten können
die Queen verlor quasi einen Enkel an
ein anderes Land einen Enkel der die
Firma verließ wie es so schön heißt doch
zugleich zeigte sie wieder einmal
Führungsstärke hier war die Königin die
mit 21 Jahren geschworen hatte dass sie
ihr ganzes Leben lang ihrem Volk und
ihrem Land dienen würde gleichgültig wie
alt sie würde und entsprechend agierte
sie erst kam die Pflicht dann die
Familie
dennoch muss ihr die ganze Angelegenheit
persönlich sehr nahe gegangen sein
und das Jahr später steht die Königin
vor einem weiteren Dilemma dieses Mal
geht es um ihren zweitältesten Sohn
Prinz Andrew dem sie ebenfalls den
königlichen Titel und seinem
militärischen Dienstgrade entzieht
der Sturz seines Herzogs dem alle von
seiner Mutter verliehenen militärischen
Titel aberkannt wurden und der sich
nicht mehr königliche Hoheit nennen darf
die Queen hat ihren Lieblingssohn
verstoßen als bekannt wurde das gegen
Prinz Andrew ein Verfahren wegen
sexuellen Missbrauchs läuft zitierte sie
ihn nach Winsor Castle und eröffnete ihm
dass er sich vor Gericht als privater
Bürger verantworten müsse
[Musik]
2020 erreicht die corona-pandemie auch
Großbritannien die Zahl der Menschen die
in Verbindung mit covid versterben
steigt dramatisch
Krankenhäuser fühlen sich bis zum
Anschlag das medizinische Personal des
National Health Service arbeitet rund um
die Uhr bis an die Grenzen der
Erschöpfung
die Nachricht dass sich auch Prinz
Charles mit dem unheimlichen Virus
infiziert hat ist ein Schock für das
britische Königshaus
die Menschen starben Unternehmen ja
ganze Branchen meldeten Konkurs an das
ganze Land war im Lockdown es war ein
Ausnahmezustand besonders für die
jüngere Generation aber selbst für die
Queen die ja als junge Prinzessin den
Zweiten Weltkrieg erlebt und ihre Rede
an die Nation gehalten hatte war all das
eine verstörende neue Erfahrung und eine
Situation die Sie in dieser Form bisher
noch nicht erlebt hatte
während sich Prinz Charles in Schottland
auf Schloss belmoral erholt bleiben die
Königin und Prinz Philip in Winsor
Castle von hier aus wendet sie sich kurz
vor ihrem 94 Geburtstag mutig und
besonnen ans britische Volk
[Musik]
erst die fünfte außerplanmäßige Rede der
Königin an die Nation
24 Millionen Menschen in Großbritannien
schauen ihr dabei zu
in dem Moment als die Königin sprach
hielt die Welt drumherum inne um
zuzuhören ihre Botschaft der Hoffnung
bedeutet den Briten unglaublich viel
die Pandemie hält das Vereinigte
Königreich und die ganze Welt in Atem
auch die Königin und Prinz Philip
bleiben in der Isolation auf Schloss
Windsor
bei ich glaube nicht dass Queen
Elizabeth und Prinz Philip jemals so
viel Zeit miteinander am gleichen Ort
verbracht haben
beide reichsten viel und das sehr oft
mit ganz unterschiedlichen Zielen und
Missionen
natürlich waren sie auch oft zusammen
jedoch nie zuvor so intensiv und
ununterbrochen wie in Jena langen Zeit
das war gewiss nicht leicht für die
beiden natürlich hatte die Queen ihren
Stab ihre Bediensteten und Kammerzofen
um sich doch der Juke of Edinburgh der
von frühester Jugend an immer aktiv und
unterwegs war hat sicher unter der
erzwungenen Abgeschiedenheit gelitten er
war jemand der immer etwas zu tun haben
musste etwas unternehmen wollte und das
ging nun nicht mehr am Ende war es
wahrscheinlich die Queen die ihn
getröstet hat
der Gesundheitszustand des prinzgemahls
verschlechtert sich dramatisch im
Februar 2021 kommt er auf Rat seines
Arztes ins Krankenhaus
ein paar Tage später fällt die
endgültige Entscheidung über die Zukunft
von Harry und Meghan die inzwischen
schon ein Jahr in Kalifornien Leben fern
der königlichen Familie es ist ein
schwerer Schritt für die Queen ihr
Enkelsohn und seine Familie werden nicht
in den Palast zurückkehren
natürlich versuchte die Königin ihm
seinen Plan freundlich auszureden musst
du das wirklich tun er wollte ja seine
Titel und den Namen für seinem
Wohltätigkeitsorganisationen behalten
doch sie war konsequent entweder du
erfüllst hier deine Pflicht als Mitglied
der königlichen Familie oder du gehst
nach Amerika wenn du nach Amerika gehst
bist du nur noch Prinz Harry da blieb
sie eisern auch wenn Sie darüber sehr
traurig war
im april 2021 wird Prinz Philip aus der
Klinik nach Hause entlassen bald darauf
erlebt die Queen den wohl
schmerzlichsten Moment ihrer
Regentschaft
[Musik]
wir unterbrechen unser Programm für eine
Meldung aus dem Königshaus darin teilt
ihre Majestät die Königinnen tiefer
Trauer mit dass ihr geliebter Mann seine
königliche Hoheit Prinz Philip Duke of
Adam brow heute morgen auf Schloss
Windsor für immer eingeschlafen ist
[Musik]
Prinz Philip war eine unglaubliche
Stütze für die Königin und der einzige
der sagen konnte was er wirklich dachte
er liebte Gedankenspiele er war immer
ein kritischer Geist der nicht
sinnerhund alles hinter verrückte
ich bin froh dass er noch einmal nach
Hause zurückkehren konnte das war ihm
sicher wichtig er hat einen starken Sinn
für Geschichte denn sowohl seine Mutter
als auch seine Großmutter wurden ja auf
Schloss Windsor geboren die Königin und
er liegt nun zur Kassel
mit seinen 99 Jahren hatte er ein langes
erfülltes und gesundes Leben gelebt und
er hatte sich seinen Waffen Geist
erhalten nun war er fort und sie war
allein er hatte sie immer unterstützt
und nie enttäuscht sie liebte diesen
Mann
was für eine Liebesgeschichte was für
ein Leben
[Musik]
am 17 April 2021 wird Prinz Philip zu
Grabe getragen bei strahlendem
Sonnenschein kommt die
Trauergesellschaft auf Schloss Windsor
zusammen
die wenigen zugelassenen Anwesenden
sitzen in großem Abstand voneinander die
Queen sitzt allein und trauert um den
Mann der 73 Jahre an ihrer Seite gewesen
war
das Bild von der Beerdigung dass sie so
ganz allein zeigt rührt die Menschen
einfach zu Tränen es war so traurig sie
so zu sehen sie hielt sich an die Regeln
warte Abstand und saß da isoliert und
ganz allein bei der Beerdigung ihres
Mannes
dieses Bild werde ich nie vergessen
das ist keines Hymer and humanowsky
mehr als 70 Jahre war Prinz Philip für
die Queen der Fels in der Brandung ein
Mann der sie stützte und ihr Kraft gab
ihr und der ganzen königlichen Familie
wer allerdings dachte dass sie nun ihre
öffentlichen Verpflichtungen
zurückschrauben würde hatte sich
getäuscht
[Musik]
in den Monaten darauf empfängt sie den
neu gewählten US-Präsidenten Joe Biden
auf Schloss Windsor und trifft die
staatschefs-gipfel in Cornwall und sie
feiert ihren 95 geburtstag
[Musik]
es Verweise dass ich sofort nach dem Tod
ihres Mannes weitergemacht hat noch in
der Woche seines Ablebens hatte sie
mehrere Termine so Meetings und
ähnliches an der Türke Kappler
dann war sie wieder permanent unterwegs
in ihrem Alter wäre ja ein Neuanfang
vermutlich schwer gefallen wenn Sie sich
für zwei oder drei Monate zurückgezogen
hätte
sie darauf hat sich verzichtet und so
erlebten wie eine enorme geschäftege
blendend aussehende Königin genauso
sollte es sein
obwohl sie älter wurde hat sie ihren
Schwung behalten und weiter das getan
was sie über 70 Jahre lang gemacht hat
Prinz Charles wird es sicher auch so
machen und William und George auch denn
das gebietet die Tradition in der Sie
alle aufwachsen Prinz Charles sagte mal
zu mir ich sage nie wenn ich einmal
König bin denn das wird der Tag sein an
dem meine Mutter stirbt und ich
unendlich traurig sein werde
wenn sie lächelt wird alles in der Welt
heller
auch wenn es bei ihrer Geburt noch nicht
klar war die Queen sollte zum Sinnbild
der britischen Monarchie werden sie hat
das Vereinigte Königreich als Mensch und
als Monarchen über vier Generationen
geprägt und die Welt in ihren Bann
gezogen schiete vor also den sie steht
für ein ganzes Jahrhundert britischen
Lebens britischer Identität sie ist in
den letzten hundert Jahren ein Teil
unseres Lebens geworden
sie verkörpert alles was die Menschen
mit unserer Fahne dem Union Jack
verbinden
sie hat der Monarchie neues Leben
eingehaucht
und ihrem Volk mit Wärme Menschlichkeit
Strenge und Tradition gedient
wenn man hier einen Titel geben wollte
so etwa wie Alfred der große dann gäbe
es für die Queen zwei Optionen Elisabeth
die entschlossene denn das war sie oder
Elisabeth die versöhnende
die Stärke der Queen war es nie ihre
wahren Gefühle zu zeigen aber immer
würde zu haben und den würde zu agieren
die Menschen zu inspirieren fokussiert
zu sein zu zeigen dass es für die
Gesellschaft wichtig ist zu wissen was
Pflicht und Pflichtgefühl ist die
Menschen resignieren heute viel zu
schnell Königin Elizabeth hat nie
aufgegeben
die britische Monarchie verdankt des
Königin Elisabeth II dass sie bis heute
relevant ist
es hat sich so viel geändert in der
Arbeit der Königin und in der Art wie
sie und die königliche Familie nach
außen hin kommunizieren mussten mit der
ganzen Technologie mit Facebook dem
Internet Zeitalter Twitter
wenn ich daran denke dass sie mit 25
Jahren in einem Alter in dem die meisten
gerade ihre Ausbildung oder ihr Studium
beenden Königin wurde und wie
enthusiastisch sie sich dieser Aufgabe
gestellt hat
es ist einfach faszinierend und das noch
im Alter von über 90 Jahren
in der neuen
mit ihrem Lächeln und das sage ich als
Fotograf ließ sie jeden Raum erstrahlen
die Queen hat verschiedene Kriege erlebt
aber auch andere Schlüsselmomente die
die Welt geprägt haben
ich glaube die Weiterführung des
Commonwealth war in ihren Augen einer
der größten Leistungen während ihrer
Herrschaft sie glaubte immer daran dass
es richtig ist wenn man eine Chance zum
Reden oder zur Zusammenarbeit nutzt wenn
etwas einem höheren gut diente dann war
es in ihren Augen gut
keine Monarchen in der gesamten
Geschichte saß länger auf dem Thron als
die Queen sie hat alles gesehen alles
erlebt wir werden Sie nicht nur als eine
der größten Königinnen der Welt erinnern
sondern auch als eine Frau die für
Modernisierung stand
[Musik]
durch die Kinder Enkel und Urenkel der
Queen lebt das Königshaus weiter Prinz
Charles ist ihr auf dem Thron gefolgt
schon im Februar 1952 als Königin
Elisabeth die Krone von ihrem Vater
übernahm weil er ihr offizieller
Thronfolger kein Monarch vor ihm musste
so lange auf seine Krönung warten
Prinz Charles ist jetzt König ich denke
er wird ein guter König besser als er
war nie jemand auf dieses Amt
vorbereitet in der 1000-jährigen
Geschichte der Monarchie ich habe über
40 Jahre für ihn gearbeitet ich weiß was
er geleistet hat er ist nicht nur der
richtige für unser Land er ist der
richtige für die Welt
wird sicher ein anderer Monarch sein als
seine Mutter
das muss auch so sein die Queen hat ja
bewiesen dass man sich weiterentwickeln
muss um zu überleben Charles weiß das
auch Ostern
Königin Elisabeth II hat mehr britische
Premierminister in ihrem Amt begleitet
und mehr Länder bereist als all ihre
Vorgänger und Vorgängerinnen
doch das Vereinigte Königreich wird sich
ihrer nicht nur wegen der langen Jahre
ihres pflichtbewussten Dienstes für ihr
Land erinnern
sie war auch die Frau auf die die Nation
in schweren Zeiten geschaut hat sie war
die Frau die die richtigen Worte fand um
ihrem Volk Hoffnung und Zuversicht zu
geben